Shakespeare's Othello opens in Venice
where we're standing now it opens in the
darkness under the windows of a house
where Iago and Roderigo are trying to
stir up trouble trouble by telling the
master of the house the importance
senator prevent Co that his daughter has
eloped with them or they start shouting
up in the darkness thieves Iago says
make it sound like there's a fire in a
populous city and so forth and bourbon
Co comes and says indignantly this is
Venice my house is not a Grange I'm not
in the country in a farmhouse this is
Venice he says it's a way of not simply
of telling the audience where the play
is located but saying something about
the nature of the city its power its
security its grandeur the absence of
threat the ridiculousness of trying to
frighten him and then he learns that he
should indeed as a father be frightened
his daughter has eloped and not only has
she eloped she's eloped with the moor a
fellow someone that bourbon Co the
senator had invited to his house to tell
the story of his life and there a fellow
and the Senators only child his daughter
Desdemona have made their acquaintance
which has developed into a love and
which has now led to her elopement
that's the opening situation Rabanne Co
the father outraged says he will rush
off to the Doge of Venice the Duke the
ruler of the whole Republic the senior
figure and he'll demand legal
satisfaction the annulment and effect of
the marriage and he declares that he has
the kind of power to do this he's one of
the most powerful figures for Anzio in
the city this Venice was an oligarchy
that is to say it was ruled by a small
number of noblemen and Rabanne Co is one
of them so he goes off confident that
his complaint will be
hurry where does he go he goes to find
the Duke in the Dukes Palace the doges
palace and that's where we are at the
moment in front of the great Dougal
Palace in Venice now what happens that
we also learned that bourbon Co is not
the only one rushing off to the ducal
palace
they have sent messages from the ducal
palace trying to find a fellow why are
they trying to find the fellow who is in
fact at that moment in an inn with his
bride Desdemona they're trying to find
him because there's a political crisis
on the one hand we have Venice the city
in all of its grandeur and security on
the other hand we have a threatened
Empire Venice was a very powerful
Republic it controlled territory not
only in its immediate surroundings but
throughout the Mediterranean as far east
as the eastern Mediterranean places like
Rhodes and Cyprus and there's a crisis a
crisis with the people at the outer edge
of Venetian power namely the other great
power in the Mediterranean the Turks the
Muslim power under the Turkish sultan
the background of Shakespeare's tragedy
is what happens at the outer edge of a
great Empire when the forces of Venice
have to meet and encounter the forces of
the enemy Turk for that encounter Venice
relies on its Navy and on its military
leaders those military leaders were not
by any means always Venetians on the
contrary for the most part they were
people from outside of Venice hired by
the Venetians especially to conduct
their battles in Venice there are very
very few statues of Venetian born
military leaders the greatest statue in
Venice of a military leader
of Bartolomeo Colleoni a great conductor
a as they call it a great military
commander and that statue is a
celebration of a man who was from
Bergamo a different city in italy hired
by the Venetians to lead its forces and
that's the situation we find at the
beginning of a fellow when we enter the
rooms in the doges palace find the
Venetian senators anxiously talking to
each other about the threat out at the
edge of their empire in Cyprus that's
the situation that is evoked at the
beginning of a fellow in which the
Venetian Senate tries to decide whom it
should send to command its garrison and
Cyprus the Venetians are powerful one of
the most powerful states in Europe they
have a great city they have wealth they
have confidence but they need military
power and their military power depends
upon foreigners foreigners like a fellow
like the character of Marcos lucha goes
who seems to have a Greek name and is in
Florence like the Florentine Cassio like
Iago who has a Spanish name virtually
all of the venetian military figures
appear to be foreigners mercenaries and
the employment of Venice so in the one
hand we have a tight cozy wealthy
confident oligarchy in Venice on the
other hand we have military leaders who
are from outside the Venice and who help
the Venetians oppose their deep enemies
their frightening enemies the Turks the
Muslim forces and all of that works more
or less fine until we have the critical
moment that's depicted in the play in
which the one of these Outsiders namely
a fellow gets alarmingly close to the
center of Venice namely the daughter of
one of the leading senators of the city
Rabanne she owes daughter Desdemona and
at that moment the
Outsiders in the employment of Venice
suddenly seem as frightening or more
frightening than the enemy Turks out
there at the edge of the Republic
you